depuis hier soir vous savez un couvre
feu est instauré à kiev la capitale où
un concentre toujours l'attention
jusqu'à demain matin les armes sont
censés ne plus raisonner pour autant on
nous signale un depuis quelques heures
de fortes explosions dans la ville il ya
aussi ces colonnes de fumée noire
s'échappant du centre ville on va
retrouver tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial johnattan wolf qui évolue aux
côtés de james andré on vous retrouve à
how beaubourg ive en périphérie sud ok
vous êtes à une trentaine de kilomètres
de la capitale ce cessez-le-feu instauré
hier soir et malgré tout ces explosions
qu'on entend est ce que vous avez des
nouvelles de ce qui se passe sur place
donnent
alors nous nous avons pour notre part
quitté hier soir le centre ville de kiev
mais nous avons contacté une journaliste
qui se trouve en ce moment sur place et
qui nous a donné à la fois les nouvelles
de cette nuit et de ce qui se passe en
ce moment même alors pour ce qui est de
cette nuit il ya eu effectivement
visiblement de violents combats et
beaucoup de tirs d'artillerie parce que
elle nous a expliqué que c'était c'était
vraiment très audible dans le ciel de
kiev durant durant la nuit impossible de
savoir évidemment de d'où ça venait
exactement d'où provenaient ces bruits
d'artillerie en tout cas pour ce qui est
de maintenant du moment où nous nous
parlons elle nous dit que la ville est
très calme alors les très calme
évidemment en terme de circulation de
civils puisque ce couvre-feu est
absolument totale et doit être doit être
respecté à la lettre mais elle nous dit
également que nous n'aurons qu'on entend
plus en ce moment à kiev ces tirs qui
résonnait sans cesse durant la nuit il
ya aussi des sources ukrainienne
plusieurs sources ukrainienne qui disent
que de violents combats ont eu lieu dans
ce dans cette zone stratégique au nord
ouest de kiev la zone dire pinet de et
de boudhha ce verrou stratégique contre
lequel poussent les forces russes depuis
maintenant des jours impossible de
confirmer officiellement ses nouvelles
mais en tout cas de nombreuses sources
sûres sur les réseaux sociaux font état
de combats dans cette zone a expliqué
nous peut-être votre départ de kiev hier
soir l annonce de ceux de ce couvre feu
la situation s'est-elle détériorer ou
lavier senti
oui alors depuis deux jours c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que la situation semblait
se détériorer il ya eu des explosions
dans c'est sûr c'est dans ces bâtiments
résidentiels dans le centre ville de
kiev et puis clairement il y avait un
contraste assez saisissant entre ce
qu'on pouvait entendre en terme de
défense anti aérienne en termes de tirs
d'artillerie même du centre-ville du
plein centre ville de kiev ces deux
derniers jours c'était devenu assez
intense et puis avec la nouvelle du
couvre-feu le lorsque nous avons quitté
hier soir en toute fin de journée le
centre de kiev pour nous rendre dans le
sud de l'oblast de kiev où nous nous
trouvons en ce moment on a pu voir
d'énormes bouchons sur la route la
circulation était vraiment très
compliqué visiblement ça a été un signal
pour beaucoup d'habitants de kiev qui
ont décidé de quitter la capitale
ukrainienne et puis on a senti aussi une
intention une tension très forte sur les
sur les checkpoints qui défendent la
capitale nous sommes passés de chacun de
ces checkpoints ou nous avons vu des
tirs où nous avons vu quelqu'un d'assez
près de nous à une centaine de mètres
tiré à la mitraillette alors on ne sait
pas exactement ce qui s'est passé à ce
moment là évidemment on ne s'est pas
arrêté pour pour le vérifier mais mais
en tout cas encore une fois la tension
était assez forte à ses fortes hier
lorsque nous avons évacué la ville
lorsque nous sommes partis de cette
ville par par cet axe sud qui est encore
aujourd'hui sécurisée par les forces de
par les forces armées ukrainiennes
merci beaucoup jonah lomu j'accompagnais
je le rappelle de james andré merci pour
ces nouveaux